plausibly unites people across all
religions Muslims Jews Christians is
that we all recognize that Rabbi Shmi is
unhinged he he's just mentally in my
view unwell and I first of all I don't
wait wait what do you mean it's true
because she said it's
true brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing D that you want to do but
we turn it into a moneymaking machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of true saram
Alum guys if you enjoy the Unholy
shimoli getting absolutely decimated and
intellectually destroyed after what
mhammed hijab done it's going to get
even better it's going to be done at the
hands of this woman cace Owens this
woman who stood by Christianity actually
should be not like those hostile
Christians like Allah says in the Quran
you know the the people of the book are
not the same and Candace Owens clearly
showed that she's consistent with a
worldview here it is how she breaks him
down step by step posibly unites people
across all religions Muslims Jews
Christians is that we all recognize that
Rabbi Shmi is unhinged he he's just
mentally in my view unwell and I don't
say that as an attack I say that as just
a reality because I've never seen
someone just make things up out of thin
air that were never said and trying to
screen that as a defense of black people
the black people will never accept Rabbi
schui after Michael Jackson put him on a
list of people who he felt were ruining
his life so you can stop your pleas with
black America they won't work I mean
that's definit agreement that the
Muslims and everybody and I even believe
Jews and even some zionists I mean Ben
Shir clearly said himself that you
believe that we control the world uh the
the media we can't even control Shi
that's right everybody believes that
he's mentally unwell he's
psychologically Disturbed have you seen
the way he's dancing twerking on that
little boy in a club in in in a party
creepy creepy as hell and this is the
ones Tommy Robinson is following by the
way let's carry on you're quoting
scripture okay the one that's relevant
to me is woe unto them that call evil
good and good evil that put Darkness for
light and light for darkness and if
you'd like to dive into a little more
scripture I think what's relevant is
revelation 3:9 behold I will make them
of the synagogue of Satan which say they
are Jews and are not but do lie and I'm
speaking directly to you Rabbi Shuli the
fact that you would try to say I am
Jewish and this is what I believe and
and do and say the things that you are
doing people can see and hear evil and
what you are doing right now is an act
of evil the lies that you are telling
not just on me but also on my family
members are a good example for the world
to see what we are referring to when we
call something radical Zionism okay and
here's what I would like to and that's
so true in the Quran inah Toba which
we're going to come to more Clips by the
way Allah talks about M where thef the
Hypocrites were Subhan Allah made a mid
a mosque but they were plotting and
planning but God Almighty says in the
Quran go to the Masjid of tawa the Masid
of righteousness so we even have this in
Islam where individuals back in the time
of the Prophet wasam or even afterward
Subhan Allah build a mosque with the aim
of plotting and planning against the
Muslims so the syue of Satan makes
perfect sense and Rabbi Shi will be the
head of he'll be the rabbi of that
but let's carry on just asked for me to
have my Visa banned simply because I
don't support what Israel is doing and
if that is what I have to pay timately
what happens I get my Visa banned
because Zionism has a lot of money in
media then so be it it's less of a price
and than the children in Gaza are paying
right now and as a Christian I will
never support what B and Yahoo is doing
right what's interesting to
me a true Christian we come across so
many Christians who who are defending
Israel at any cost you can see Candace
ens is not the same that's what Allah
tells us the people of the book are not
the same she is standing up for justice
she's been speaking against the Zionist
that they are willing to they are going
to try trying to in revoke her visa and
she's saying if the Bloodshed is going
to stop of innocent Palestinian kids Let
It Be credit is given where credit is
Jew can this Owens you are an absolute
champ in this very aspect and you know
what we are fully behind you like Subhan
Allah when the prophet Muhammad PE upon
when the Romans were fighting the
Persians and the Persians defeated the
Romans but the Romans and the pro the
Quran prophesized that the Romans will
come back and defeat the the Persians
the companions of the Prophet Muhammad
if upon him were also rejoicing because
simultaneously they won the battle
against the evil which was the Pagan
Arabs in the Battle of bad and they were
also happy the muas didn't say that they
heard the Romans defeat the Persians
were also known as Idol worshippers so
we stood by the Christians then and we
will stand by Christians like cace Owens
today because she speaking the H the
Israeli in the New York Times the
Israeli Defense Force had dropped more
bombs on Gaza then were dropped on
Resident that is true do you accept that
Rabbi schy you know you you know Pi I
you
first of all I don't wait wait what do
you mean it's true because she said it's
true
do is this a serious show wait wait wait
wait every time I ask for called it a
blood she made excuse me you are
interrupting me she made a definitive
statement she admitted she had no Source
she had to then use her computer it's
absurd that she has a computering
because because she had she had to look
it up one second now now she's saying
that over that over an 11mon war no we
don't know that she's right this is why
we say he's mentally unwell because you
can clearly see a simple fact that given
he's still fighting it and going against
it because they're absolute liers these
Zionist radical extremists are absolute
scumbags and you can very clearly say
that and that's the reason why canand
this 's got a laptop to fact she takes
her time to tell the truth the reason
you don't have a computer is because
you've got a machine your brain which is
a uh which is perpetually lying but here
is one very important point of who RAB
Unholy sholi is um Mentor is here's what
Candace Owen had to leak one of the
things that the world is recognizing and
what we've always recognized is that
there are radical Fringe sex that break
out within every single religion amongst
every race there's white supremacy
there's black Supremacy there's radical
Islam there are all of these Christ
Cults around the world and I think right
now it's important for people to
understand that radical Judaism is also
a thing and you just you're watching an
example of it right now on your screen
the person sitting across from me or
sitting sitting next to me I guess it
posted on his Facebook page in 2016 a
tribute to someone who he said was his
mentor that was Rabbi menam sersen he
said he was his mentor and his friend
now for those of you are not familiar
with Rabbi schneerson there were some
Jews uh uh who believed that Rabbi Schon
listen carefully who is he he believed
he was the Messiah we as Muslims and the
Christians believe the Messiah is who
Jesus we accept that and he's going to
kill the Antichrist we believe that but
they believe he was the Messiah and look
at some perverted ideas he had about who
the goyum is goyum is anyone that is not
a uh Jew this is what they believed in
him and this is course to Tommy Robinson
and all the people the scumbag dirt bags
that suppor zist this is what they
really think of you you flipping clown
that they are using you for a bit of
money look there listen to it very
carefully was the Messiah what is it
that becomes important to understand
what did Rabbi schneerson preach well he
preached Jewish supremacism the hatred
of all non-jews and you don't have to
take my word for it because if I said it
they would say that's anti-Semitism you
should instead take the word of the two
Jewish professors who translated his
work those authors names were Israel
shahak and Norton mezvinsky and their
book was entitled Jewish fundamentalism
in Israel from that book we learn that
shmi's Mentor schneerson describes the
difference between a Jew and a non-jew
and he says quote thus we do not have a
case of profound change in which a
person is merely on a superior level the
body of a Jewish person is of totally
different quality from the body of all
nations of the world and he talk nutsh
they believe this guy's Mentor that we
as the goyum yes the Gentile is we're
like a whole different species that is
the reason why they are systematically
killing and butchering Palestinians
because that is what they believe not
only just the Palestinians they believe
the same about you far right dirt bags
that are supporting Zionism you are the
same when the time comes the Messiah
comes you guys are going to be
slaughtered that's all I have to say
hope you guys enjoyed Candace Owens or
she was said Candace oven yes who is
cooking cooking this Unholy shimoli in
high temperatures and he is cooking
brother and sisters alhamdulillah as you
can see alhamdulillah Allah subhana tala
will Expose and the truth will come out
Subhan Allah I hope you guys have
enjoyed this in brother and sisters and
may Allah bless you don't forget to
support our brothers and sisters with
the w Pro inah